- Is it true that you wrote
a secret song that nobody
else has ever heard and you
put it in a time capsule?
- Yes, and that has drove me crazy.
- Because people bring it up?
- No, yeah, because they bring it up,
but because I have written
a song that nobody's going
to hear 'til I'm 99 years
old and I might be there,
I might not be, but it's
when we did Dollywood,
when reworked that, and we put
it in a time capsule to be,
you know, to be opened.
- Kind of honor the opening, yeah.
- And so,
and I put all the things that
had to do with the times.
I put a cassette player and
I put all the CD player.
I put stuff all in this box
that if it would preserve it
to how we played those,
you know, at the time.
But I put that in the box,
but I had to write this song
that nobody was going to hear 'til then.
And I tell you have no idea
how that has bothered me.
I wanna go dig that up so bad and think,
well, I need to use that
song 'cause it's like,
you know, and it's a really good song.
But, yes, I have a song that's buried
that nobody's gonna hear 'til,
I don't know whose damn idea that was.
- Yeah, you're like, when is the cut-off?
Is there a date, do you know?
We need to find the date
'til we get to unearth it.
- So I'm 76 and it's
when I'm 99 years old.
- It is when you're 99?
- Yeah, I'd be 99 years old
when they open it, yeah.
- Dolly, you got like a lot
more time to wait for that one.
- I know.
(Kelly laughs)
- But they weren't expecting
me to be there at all.
- Well that's just rude.
- And I probably won't be.
(both laugh)
- [Kelly] That's just rude.
- But I mean, I'm just saying
I might be there, who knows.
But the point is that
there is a song I figure
it'd probably disintegrate,
probably nobody ever hear it.
That's what bothers me to think
that it's gonna be a song that
nobody's ever going to hear
if it rots in there before they open it.
- But what beautiful thing
though, when they open it.
What a beautiful thing.
I love, I'm totally,
and I've done time capsule
gifts before, more as a joke,
like I gave Blake Shelton a time capsule
for his birthday last year to
open it, the one this year.
And it was just like my team
Kelly jacket from The Voice.
(both laugh) And I was, 'cause
he kept throwing it away,
and I was like, "You've had
this for a year. Joke's on you."
So, but anyway, I've
done it in a funny way
but I've never done it in a serious way.
And I think that's most beautiful, too,
for like people to do for like their kids,
like make something for their kids.
If you can't sing, like make a video
and like have them
unearth it at some point.
I think that's really special.
- Well, it'll be,
hopefully it'll be special
and hopefully you'll still be there.
- Y'all enjoy it. (laughs)
- Some of you might be,
some of you might not.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, I love it.
But it's true though, but it's not fear,
I have to honestly say
it was a odd feeling
to be asked to write a
song that nobody was,
not going to hear.
I mean, it was not gonna be heard.
- That is annoying, it is, yeah.
- But it's a good song, too.